so Disney was producing some of the
biggest hits the world has ever seen The
Little Mermaid a lot of people saw
Beauty and the Beast most people saw
Aladdin everybody saw and The Lion King
was the highest-grossing animated film
at that time what could possibly go
wrong for dis I am
yes Pocahontas seems to be that snowball
that started the avalanche of downward
spiraling Disney animated films it
wasn't a big critical disappointment or
even that big a financial disappointment
but nobody praised it like they praised
the other Disney films especially the
general public not just adults but even
kids found the whole idea of telling the
story of the Indian princess to be well
not that interesting and the 2d Disney
animated films would never quite hit the
record breaking numbers that they did
with Lion King Aladdin and so forth
after this came out so is it as bad as
everybody made it out to be hey let's
look at the good stuff first of all you
got give Disney credit for trying
something pretty different with this I
mean for a company that mostly based its
animated films on fairy tales and pop
cultural references this was a very
different turn even the look of the film
is different the soft smooth lines are
not really as prominent and look even
the eyes of really shrunken down the
characters don't look like the typical
Barbie and Ken stereotype that you get
in most Disney films but I think people
kind of miss that I think there's just
something so jarring when your last
human characters look like this and then
suddenly they look like this maybe a
more adult look is fine if there's a
more adult story and that is not at all
what this is I'm not even gonna try and
talk about the history aspect of this
cuz trust me there's no point they made
most of it up but that wouldn't matter
as much if it was done well but pretty
much what we have is the typical greedy
white guy comes to take over the native
land a story that adults and especially
kids have heard over and over and over
and after-school specials are they right
yeah but can you find a new way of
telling it I think a lot of us don't see
the purpose in watching a story if we
already know exactly what's gonna happen
and pretty much how you're going to tell
it okay let's get to the technicals here
our main lead is Pocahontas she's strong
free spear
it in and dull as a rock yeah I'm sorry
she's just not that interesting I mean I
know she does things that the other
princesses don't do but her actions are
one thing her personality is something
different
she's not bad she's just not that fun to
watch the only person to be more boring
is John Smith played by Mel Gibson him
and his crew come across the Native
Americans and decide they want to take
over their land which leads to teaching
the white idiots a new point of view
constant misunderstandings that of
course result in capture and death and
an evil bad guy who refuses to listen
and just what's gold gold gold it's your
classic who's the savage story which
like I said wouldn't be bad if they
could do something new with it and for
those thinking that this was one of the
first films to try it it's not like I
said this stuff was in countless
after-school specials and TV shows and
all sorts of things geared towards kids
so this was really nothing that
unexpected one of the biggest complaints
at the time is that the animals don't
talk and at first I kind of liked it I
like a little mind silent school stuff
where you don't hear them talk and it's
all in the expressions but then when you
really think about it this is a film
about communicating with nature why
don't the animals talk if there's any
Disney movie where it actually makes
sense to hear the animal speak this is
it but if they don't want to make them
talk that's fine
maybe they're communicating with nature
in another way like you know talking to
the trees wait a minute the trees can
talk but the animals can't what sense
does that make
yeah I don't get it either as a pre
silly choice now wait a minute didn't I
say I was gonna talk about the good
things in this movie cuz there are a few
most of us know colors of the wind and
even though it's preachy it's still a
pretty decent song I really like savages
even though the lyrics at times are a
little goofy
another thing that's really cool about
this movie is the colors they look great
you sort of don't even see the lights
the colors just sort of take them over
whoever did the artistic design really
knew what they were doing and once in a
while you get some cute comic relief
from the little animal friends but aside
from that there's not much to talk about
is it really awful I suppose not I mean
it's not doing anything god-awful apart
from you know rewriting history
but hey history already did that and
it's Disney you expect them to take
horrifying stories and change them
around to have a happy ending but
Pocahontas biggest crime is
it's dull and predictable now the Disney
has always been unpredictable but it's
always been entertaining focus is just a
snorefest apart from looking at it
there's really not that much to have fun
with we already know what the lessons
gonna be we already know the characters
are gonna discover we already know their
flaws their strengths their weaknesses
we already know who's gonna die we
already know who's gonna live so why are
we watching it well a lot of people
didn't like I said this was the first
film to start the sort of animated
Disney downfall and even though they'd
still have some hits after it none of
them would ever reach the golden age
that Disney hit a few years earlier so
while it's not awful I can see why it
started this downward spiral Disney
would need to have a truly ingenious
idea for their next film to pull them
out of it the result
well join me in the next one
you